it sucks it definitely but i've always
felt that way it's a it's
it's weird to just be up there and like
most comedy clubs
and venues like they got security but
like
no one's really thinking you you're
taking care of people that might be too
sauced up or that are
just um you know a distraction and
not in terms of like someone's gonna
rush the stage and again it does happen
but like
i've rarely seen i mean there's a kid up
in seattle i know that got hit at an
open mic with a guy
he uh with a bat and um i mean dude he
was like a half a centimeter away from
like just that being a wrap and he had
all these
skull and brain surgeries and now he's
living a great life and and not doing
stand-up anymore still doing it not as
much
but yeah but like just at an open mic
like a guy he wouldn't let on a show
came back the following week because the
guy was like awful and always be drunk
and was like just being rude to people
and so he said you can't come to a guy
came anyway and hit him with the bat and
his head yeah
and that type of [ __ ] makes me go oh
yeah there's nothing to stop and this
guy last night like how do you get
through
there's always
there's also so you're putting yourself
out do you ever feel like that because
you're always you're always like people
are heckling you and you're always
you know free free bowling just going
out there and just rocking off the cuff
off the cuff and you say [ __ ] do you
ever worry about uh this guy just said
that to you and he looks a little pissed
maybe and uh
i'll comment on that during the show to
the guy if that if i truly feel like
it's
but then like that just happened in
irvine a few weeks ago and then there
was this big guy named gustavo that i
was having some fun with and so then it
became a thing of like
gustavo's got my back if this guy tries
to pull some [ __ ] but
but but then i always try to kill it
with kindness and make sure that i'm not
ever and that's something about my crowd
work that i don't like that i learned
from our boy harland was
uh a to listen and be
uh
to not be a dick about it and like
hit the hit em and hug him thing you
know i'm saying where it's like we all
gotta [ __ ] with people so get a little
that but then like you know bring it in
be like i'm just [ __ ] around you know
marlins is the he says the mo i mean he
is the king of random [ __ ] oh yeah i
just there's only one no there's only
one harlan williams he's like sir have
you ever uh made love to a dairy queen
uh blizzard on a hot saturday night
uh no well you're not living or you will
yeah